Peggy 18 it started with the meeting  everyone was there  scarecrow said he had a plan that  together we could take you out and  Gotham would be ours over my dead body I  believe  was the idea  remnants of Gotha I have messages for  you all to the Vandals who stayed behind  to ping the still warm flesh from  Gotham's bones have you fun you are  under my protection  to the cowards breaking behind the  police departments walls you will come  to me spare  and to Batman I have already won  emptied your city was the vial of toxin  mfu shredder that's how little the  safety you provided with words  and when the dawn come  when Gotham lysing ruined and I turned  my gaze to the world beyond  man  we worth nothing  you